in 1879 Thomas Edison perfected his most
iconic invention the incandescent light
bulb it was nice while it lasted in
September the European Union outlawed
100 watt light bulbs imposing fines of
up to 70 thousand dollars on law
breakers over the next few years bans on
lower wattage incandescence will kick in
eventually resigning Edison signature
invention to the dustbin of history
similar legislation kicks in in the
United States in 2012 the goal is to
jumpstart the market for compact
fluorescent light bulbs or cfls CFLs use
less electricity than conventional light
bulbs and are pitched as a way to
decrease energy use they also come with
a load of problems for starters CFLs can
take up to three minutes to warm up and
work best if left on for more than 15
minutes they cost up to 10 times as much
as incandescent and while they're
supposed to last up to 15 times longer
than an incandescent frequent turning on
and off decreases the lifespan today's
CFLs contain mercury which makes
disposal a problem and some interfere
with radios and other electronic
equipment most of them can't be used in
hanging light fixtures and closed
fixtures dimmer switches there with
garage door openers or ceiling fans or
other things that vibrate and the light
they cast is inferior but like it or not
Edison's most ubiquitous invention will
start to become illegal in the US come
2012 the latest bright idea from
regulators that increasingly tell us
what we can and can't do in public and
in private from smoking to trans fat to
gambling it's all been banned somewhere
for over a hundred years the light bulb
was synonymous with genius now it's just
one more symbol of the nanny state for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie